hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com so very quickly let me
introduce myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i decided to make a youtube channel
because i wanna explain to you guys all
the different tools and techniques that
i use to make money on the markets
and most importantly i want you guys to
understand
how i do it so that you are able to do
it yourself
so let's get into it and have a look at
clvs
[Music]
i did a video last week where i
basically was
saying so let's go on a daily timeframe
first to just
sum up a bit the situation on clds so i
was
bullish on clvs for very long time guys
since we had like this breakout
and actually you know the retest
was expected and i was saying
that we gonna go higher after that
because this is how things usually
happen we have the breakout we re-tested
we go higher
what i think is very bullish when i look
at this
so for now guys of course i'm bullish
you know
because this is i mean just part of the
plan we have some
messy consolidation here but it's all
right
look at the volume here i mean you know
it's insane and on the bullish day
so there were a lot of buyers a lot of
buyers and this
is a very bullish sign when on the
strong days the volume is high
this is giving more uh relevance
importance
to what the price action is saying
because the flows
are heavy so now let's go on the forward
time frame
and let's zoom in you know step by step
so on the fourth time frame you still
have this very strong volume
and what you can see guys is that first
now let's go to i will eat them frame i
think the signals are better
on the hourly time frame guys what you
can see so
what is interesting is this breakout the
breakout happened
but it's a breakout of what you know you
need to find
what we broke out to know where the
re-test might happen
so you need to find the resistance level
that were around this level and you know
to me
what i see is actually two different
things the price action so before this
move
the price action was actually contained
uh
here first below the 200 period moving
average
we break it we retest it we are
below all these moving averages then
here we start to go higher
i mean those ones they have bad
reactions all right so i don't even use
them
but the 200 period moving average has
actually good signal i mean broken
retested we go lower then here i can see
that
the price action was actually contained
here
we have some consolidation we don't
manage to
break it here again we test it so one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10
hours of trading we were testing this
level so this is my breakout level
6 30 and the 200 period moving average
as well
had only two but nice and clean
reactions
so those on the hourly time frame are
what i'm gonna
uh check and here what you can see
is actually that we retested this level
so once again i did this analysis after
seeing this
so it's easier i agree guys i agree but
i'm just trying to you know find
something that makes sense
and you know it's never easy to find
things before they happen it's always
easy to do what we call back training
but what i'm doing guys here is actually
giving you
a lot of levels prior of
before the press action is actually
happening and once the press action
happened i'm
explaining to you guys what happened so
here what happened is actually that 6 30
was the breakout level
and we are just retesting it so for me
on the short term we are still very
bullish
so now what i expect is uh maybe a bit
more of consolidation around this level
if we break it the the situation would
be very different
we would probably go again to revisit
this
support level that is the major one
around 5 30 we are then have 460 below i
mean
everything here is of course you know a
very beautiful
uh level to buy but i believe that 630
is gonna hold for the reasons i told you
for the the fact that the volume are
very very large and huge
so i think that the momentum is very
bullish we just had like a
you know bearish week on all the
different red stocks
and i'm i'm kind of confident in the
fact
that we are gonna trade higher uh next
week
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys